we have no creative constraints because
it's a video game and the rules of the
video game are being established kinda
as we go along and that's the beauty of
this ah the gangs back together nothing
compares to a soul snatching enchanted
video game to really forge the bonds of
friendship I'm ready to see these stars
back in action so here's everything you
need to know before you go
[Music]
Jumanji the next level is the third
iteration to come from the Jumanji
franchise it's a direct sequel to
Jumanji welcome to the jungle but up
first
what is Jumanji you might ask it was a
board game in the 1995 original film
starring Robin Williams and in the 2017
film we saw in the form of a video game
but to take it back a bit further did
you know the fantasy adventure franchise
was adapted for the screen from a 1981
children's book by the same name
Jumanji the picture book written and
illustrated by Chris Van osburgh was
about a magical board game that applies
elements of the jungle to its players
real-life setting the original Jumanji
film released in 1995 brought the pages
of the picture book to life the cast
included the wonderful Robin Williams
along with Kirsten Dunst David Alan
Grier Bonnie Hunt Bradley Pierce
Jonathan Hyde and Bebe Neuwirth just
like the book the story follows the
adventures of Judy and Peter two
siblings who discovered and played
Jumanji and of course they had no idea
that trapped inside it was Alan Parrish
who had played the board game 26 years
prior Alan Cera Judy and Peter are taken
on a wild adventure as the twists and
turns of the game unleash stampedes a
monsoon terrifying animals and even
transforms Peter into one and the only
way to end the chaos is to complete the
game did you know the Jareau a space
adventure released in 2005 also written
by Chris Van osburgh is a part of the
Jumanji universe but unlike the book the
film has no direct tie to the other
Jumanji films there was also Jumanji
animated series that lasted three
seasons from 1996 to 1999 centered
around Judy and Peter okay and now on to
the 2017 sequel just like its
predecessor Jumanji welcome to the
jungle got crazy so remember how I said
that Jumanji evolved into a video game
this is where we see that take shape
instead of the game elements being
pushed into the real world
players were sucked into the game itself
and had to navigate the jungle and some
wacky obstacles oh when the best part is
that just like most video games each
player picked an avatar to represent
them on the challenges of the virtual
journey
Spencer is Dwayne Johnson phryges Kevin
Hart Bethany is Jack Black and Martha is
karen gillan Alex I don't exactly know I
tell you this game for 20 years that's
probably not how I would have done it
much like the original Jumanji there is
a player stuck inside the game that must
be free and it becomes the player's
mission to help him return home along
with them and this one doesn't
disappoint we get our happy ending the
group was on rocky ground when they
first entered the game but by the end
their bonds are sealed by their
unbelievable time in the wild there's
even some romance between Spencer and
Martha
[Music]
that was I was so off never like I've
never kissed you no never
Oh Jumanji welcome to the jungle grossed
worldwide a total of nine hundred and
sixty two point 1 million and at April
2018 the film passed spider-man
homecoming to become Sony's highest
grossing film domestically and now are
you ready to take it up a notch and
Jumanji the next level the gang of
friends is back together but this time
they have to enter the game to rescue
one of their own Spencer the gang ends
up back in Jumanji when Spencer the
character who I played in the original
one he he's actually he's grown unhappy
with his life and after becoming dr.
smolder brave stone in the first Jumanji
he felt like he had it all he decides
that he wants to go back in the game
and all of his friends are like are you
crazy
they've also got two new players
Spencer's grandfather played by Danny
DeVito and his friend Milo played by
Danny Glover Plus everyone is playing as
an avatar different from who they were
previously Danny DeVito turns into me
Danny Glover turns into Kevin Hart
Dwayne Johnson plays grandpa Eddie
Kevin Hart is Milo Karen Gillan seems to
be the same person Martha and Jack Black
is fridge but then somehow switches back
to Bethany prior to that she was a horse
in the game for a bit
poor girl Nick Jonas is also back along
with noir alum aka Aquafina joining the
cast the game is familiar with where you
left off so because we conquered the
stage that we were given a task to
conquer and the last one we don't have
the same mission so now you know and now
you can go see Jumanji the next level in
theaters December 13
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]